Filling out with beats so sleek.
Sebastian
Seated guy, the geek.
Runmeets has
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, known across the
Internet as Rawkode. And today, we continue the
Rawkode live series where we take a look
at awesome open source software that will make
your cloud native lives all that little bit
easier.
And today, we're taking a look at a
project that I've been adopting within the Rawkode
Academy itself, which makes us an extra fun
episode.
And I am joined by
cofounder and CTO, Sebastian. Hey. How's it going,
man? Hey.
It's it's going good. How are you?
Yeah. Good. I'm
I'm just bobbing along to the electronic music.
You know? I'm I'm really I think the
AI like, I know people are probably gonna
just go on with the show already, but
maybe AI music, it it puts a smile
on my face before we go live. So
what more can you ask for? I I
think it's great. I mean, I also love
hearing my name in it, and I'm not
usually I don't love having attention on me,
but I will definitely listen to that in
my car.
No attention on you, but I'm gonna put
the spot right on you right now and
ask you to introduce yourself to the audience
and share a little bit about you.
Will do.
Alright. So my name is Sebastian. I'm the
CTO at Stateful, and we make runme. I
I'm kinda all decked out, so Stateful is
the company. Right? We have no idea. It's
a merit. And and runme is the project
that we're making, which is essentially
open source technology.
I've been in sort of the cloud cloud
native ecosystem
for a couple of years now.
Spent a lot of time at Sauce Labs
helping with, like, test automation
and then made my way into cloud native
PKI,
you know, service meshes and the TLS mutual
TLS aspect of that. And, you know, about
four years ago, kinda went on this journey
to start a company and,
worked through this,
problem that I still think is unsolved,
but, like, I think runme closes the gap.
Well, I'm hoping that runme will close the
gap where
I think we our tool chain is too
fragmented. Right? We have a we have a
terminal. We have a browser. We have an
editor. We have a cloud console.
And anytime we we use one or the
other, we actually have to switch into another
tool. And I call these sort of, like,
default lines between, you know, the seventies I've
created with POSIX, Unix, and and the process
model that's been so successful.
But in the long run, you know, essentially,
it's a lot of tech debt. You know?
I'm saying this in a in a sort
of, like, loving way because I am also
in love with the terminal.
So before we obviously, before I get too
deep into that,
what came out of that is sort of
the idea of flipping it on its side
using a notebook UX to bring all these
different tools into one place.
And then also, you know, layer a a
CLI, you know, not over it, but, like,
over the same core, you know, so you
can have sort of a multimodal way of
interacting
with, you know, tools
those tools and, you know, the workflows that
you're describing, the task that you're describing,
that sort of stuff. And I really enjoy
talking about this stuff, and I can get
really deep into, you know, Chrome architectures and
all that. But, like, I'll leave it at
that intro, and I'm sure we'll get into
it.
Yeah. I like that early on you've already
mentioned, like, multimodal.
So, you know, before we go live, you
know, full disclosure, I was talking about all
the different things I've tried in the past
to do this exact thing. You know, there
are there are no shortage of tools out
there, but what I I really appreciated in
light and why I've stuck with runme is
just that I do wanna work on the
command line except when I don't, and I
do wanna work in Versus Code except when
I don't. And, like, that is definitely the
differentiator. If I want, I can use the
CLI and people will see that, you know,
shortly as we get into it. But if
I'm already in Versus Code and I just
wanna run something, the button's, like, right there.
And I love that you're not really forcing
too many opinions on me. I mean, there
are obviously opinions, but I get to work
the way I wanna work with my tools
and that keeps me happy every single time.
I say this every episode almost, like, don't
take my tools away from me. Give me
enrich my tools in some way. And I
Yeah. You gotta meet people where they are.
Right? I mean, it was kinda, like, one
of the choices that informed
you know, we did a lot of development
that,
you know, like, makes that possible that, like,
you know, almost is invisible. It's sort of
like the stuff we are it's a little
bit like how Apple designs product. It's like,
you don't really see how much work goes
into making it so so easy and so,
you know, frictionless.
And you just kinda assume that's how it
is. And, you know, that's one of the
big design principles. I kinda meet people where
they are. And as much as I, you
know, throw the POSIX, you know, and the
process model and the UNIX history under the
bus, right, I'm doing it in a in
a way where I'm like, I still don't
wanna I don't wanna go to a WASM
and say, like, goodbye. I'm out of here.
Right? Because I know that, you know, we're
both on the shoulder of giants. Right? And
we kinda have to meet people where they
are. Yeah.
I'll throw out one other little not really
a story, maybe just like an anecdote. But
I would say three months ago, I was
fully committed to saying goodbye to Markdown from
my entire life, like every repository, my mono
repository, the whole work.
And I'll throw Martin under the bus as
I do not think it is
what it's not up it's not set for
purpose, right, for what we need it to
do. And I started adopting AsciiDoc across all
of my repositories because it's really extensible to
the point where I can,
you know, import lines from a make file,
justify whatever and to my my readme. But
then you lose GitHub support. You lose the
GitLab support for Joe, Gitty, whatever you're using,
like, everything has built on markdown to the
point where I was just like, well, screw
all these services. I'm gonna ask you doc.
And I think runme was probably the tool
that made me go, you know what? Let's
just stick with markdown because this is really
cool. And
I don't think markdown is set for purpose,
but I think the way
that runme integrates with the markdown is different
from what I've seen in the past and
that it almost feels like it worked. Like,
I I still feel like I'm writing markdown,
which is nice. Whereas other tools, they always
expect me to do weird structures with headings
or they expect me to do code box
for metadata and front matters and stuff like
that.
There's they share some of those things. I
had some commonality,
but does stick to strictly Martin code blocks,
which I thought was a really neat really
neat trick. I mean, that's that's good to
hear. I I just I wanna say Monday
or Tuesday, I forget exactly Wednesday, probably most
of the day deep down in an abstract
syntax tree of markdown
to, like, really just iron out one of
those little kind of things that you run
into. And we spend a lot of time
really making it so that, like, even when
you when you modify something in the notebook
editor, then you get the minimal diff. Right?
Like, we preserve,
you know, like, lines at the end and
you know? So so, I mean, there's a
lot of stuff work that goes into it.
So, you I'm glad you're saying that because,
like, conceivably, we could build an ASCII doc
AST into the notebook, kinda like, you know,
at the end of the day, it's like
decoding, encoding.
But I'm not looking forward to build another,
you know, AST
transformer that, you know, like,
works out all those kings, but at least
not in the short term. But I I
agree. Like, am I in love with markdown?
Is there something better? Maybe. But, like, it's
everywhere. Right? It's like it's it's the same
relationship I have with the terminal where I'm
like, it I know it so well that
it's like, I type faster than anything else,
but I also understand that, like, it has
it has a difficult it has difficulties with,
like, sharing
workflows,
sharing what you're doing, and bringing in, like,
you know, more graphical concepts. Right? Like, a
UI is a is a really, like, from
a fidelity point of view, dump down way
of, like, making user interfaces available. Right? So
it's yeah. But I'm I'm glad you're saying
that, And I'm happy we brought that to
you.
Yeah. I I mean, I don't think anything
there are better tools. Right? But than to
markdown.
But Absolutely. You can't fight the gravity of
it. It is ubiquitous and you just gotta
lean into that. And yeah. To pairing it
with runme solved all my problems where my
documentation becomes
living. And that that was really what I
was trying to achieve. Right? It wasn't that
I I was at markdowns, like, good enough.
Have to replace it. It's just that I
want my documentation. I want to I want
guarantees. I want proof. I want physical
proof that that works. That still works across
Yeah. Emily. I mean, like, one one of
those sort of design principles that I just
talked about was, like, you know, meeting people
where they are. Right? Another one is,
you know, like, to to get to a
place where our documentation is not just a
thing off to the site. Right? It's not
like an afterthought. It's not something that you
you kinda, like, copy and paste a bunch
of stuff that you currently did, and then
you edit it somewhere and paste it into
a markdown document irrespective whether it will actually
run or not. Right? And there's obviously all
sorts of reasons why it might not run,
but, like, oftentimes, you would be surprised, and
I'm sure you've experienced that too, that people
just made up make up command line flags,
then they started it. Right? Like, out of
them, Terraform apply has the same ones as
Terraform plan, but in actuality, that's not true.
So the idea of using, you know, like,
those tools that we use to get work
done and how we document it so we
can essentially, you know, have the best parts
of both worlds. Right? The written word to
contextualize
the code. And, you know, when I say
code, mean commands here too and API calls
for that matter to to get the work
done. Right? To actually do the how. Right?
That that is sort of, like, something that,
like, I think is underappreciated.
Right? And, like, I I feel like once
you get on random to runme and then
it seems like you kinda gotten over that
hump here, you kinda make that realization that,
like, now I actually have working documentation,
and I have my make targets. Right?
So
so you essentially get to this place where,
like, you know, now it's now it's one
of the same thing. It's like documentation, but
also how you interact with the world and
how you get your work done. Right? And
I think that's very powerful, and and we
are so nihilistic about documentation. Like, I mean,
sometimes I feel like I shouldn't even start
with the word documentation. We put people to
you now. They're like, has never worked. Undone
here. Goodbye. Right? And that's that's a that
that's kinda like what we wanna change. Right?
Because it doesn't have to be that way.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Let's say hi to Ravi and Kat.
Kat has plus one for the Ascii doc
support,
so I guess you're gonna have to ship
that now. Sorry.
But the
the tides are cheap. I mean, that's it.
Kat's been putting stuff on my, you know,
my to do list, you know, which are
all good, good. And I'm I'm I'm trying
to tick them off, but I think we
might have to do
during before we do Asciidoc.
Nice. Well, we're gonna get hands on in
just a few minutes. But before we do
that, I'm curious just about the the history.
Right? You you give us a bit of
background about yourself and the cloud native.
I'm assuming at some point you woke up
and when I wanna solve documentation and mark
that and and runme popped out of your
head. Like, maybe you could just share a
bit more about what the pain points were,
why you decided to build this thing, and
and how you managed to turn it into
a company.
Yeah. So,
it's kinda interesting because, like, you know, when
it comes to the company's trajectory, the company
actually came first.
And we did, you know, what, like, in
startup, Lan is called a pivot.
After we we, you know, sort of, like,
you know, discovered is probably a better word
than, like, you know, created runme. And I
I'm, like, of a big I'm a big
believer that, like, when it comes to both
technology and products, you discover them. You don't
you don't build them. I mean, you you
you hone them and you refine them, which
is in the building process.
So the company came first for two years,
and we're trying to figure out
if there's a way we can quantify,
you know, developers'
sort of activity in a way where they
can learn from their own metrics,
sort of, like almost like a health tracker,
but, like, for yourself, not for
I mean, definitely not for your manager. Right?
Not for other people, but so that you
can more or less compete with yourself. Right?
And I think we ran into some real
issues there,
which is not even worth talking about. But,
like, we decided to sort of, like, you
know,
abandon it, I would I would say. But
we we we always were kinda, like, focused
on building on the Versus Code platform. Right?
So so runme is built on the Versus
Code platform. I think that's important to say
because the main, you know, like, application
that's bundled and distributed is is is Versus
Code desktop. Right? But, you know, there's Codespaces,
GitPods,
Google IDX,
Codespaces, yada yada yada, and and Coda server.
Right? That is essentially the same relationship, you
know, all these tools have is the is
is is very much was very similar to
how Chromium
powers Chrome and Brave and I mean, without
without the UI, you know, even Edge. Right?
I mean, has the same rendering engine. And,
like, you know so we so we were
always, like, really focused on, like, this is
a ubiquitous platform. It's kinda like building on
iOS. Right? So we learned a lot, you
know, from building these two years of this
sort of, like, coding metrics
idea and and vision. And we learned a
lot about, you know, the ins and outs
of of Versus Code. Right? And then when
we decide, okay. Well, this this concept, we
can't get it legs. Right?
Let's let's figure out what's next. We we
kinda like my my cofounder, Adam, and I,
we're kinda introspective, and we spent a lot
of time at Sauce Labs building, like, cloud
infrastructure from the ground up. And when I
say from the ground up, I really mean,
like, data center, power density,
you know, like like, really from the ground
up. Not, like, you know, deploying into AWS.
I wish we it was as easy, in
your quotes, as doing that, but we had,
like, such esoteric requirements for the hardware that
we have to build our own data centers.
And, you know, in that whole process,
it's just like there's so much work that
you have to do and so many moving
pieces,
and there's no TerraForm to do that for
you. There's no I mean, at the time,
was probably a grant. Right? And we just
kinda, like, came back to this point of,
there's no way
to describe
what we're doing in documentation
that doesn't match the shelf life of a
milk carton, right, where the moment you write
it, it's basically outdated. Right? So
kinda starting with a very simple idea of,
like, basically what you described earlier where it's
like, you know, there's a NPM install where
a Go gets, you know, something where Go
installs something.
In my readme, right in front of me,
fully rendered. Why can't I click a play
button? Right? And
using that sort of, like, near simple idea
and then looking at the Versus Code platform
that essentially has APIs
for extensions
to build notebooks because they essentially retrofitted the
Jupyter notebooks inside of Versus Code. We just
kinda, like, kinda connected those dots.
But before we even did that, we started
with the CLI because we were like, well,
we can parse markdown into an abstract syntax
tree and then, you know, sort of noodle
through,
you know, your markdown document and figure out
what's code and what isn't and make that
executable.
And we shipped a little binary at the
time. It was called RDME,
like, you know, sort of like a a
shorter version of readme,
and and launched it. And I wrote a
blog post about it, and it was like
I think we dropped it on f two,
and it was, like, the highest traffic piece
for for the whole week. I mean, we're
kinda blown away. Like, interestingly,
what I found was that more people
the concept resonated more than I think the
implementation because the implementation was so rough. It
was basically an alpha prototype kind of thing.
But that really kinda, like, gave us more
more confidence in, like, pursuing that direction, And
I think that really crossing
over into the notebook
without leaving a CLI behind was also, like,
kinda, like, a big
evolution.
And and I wanna say, like, two months
later, we shipped something on runme.dev.
That's kinda how the website the the project
website was created.
And we dropped it on the Internet. I
I don't even remember we had someone read
it, and we just got hit with a
tsunami of traffic. And we somehow got on
hacker views. I think we were, like, in
the top 50.
And that, you know, that kinda, like, sort
of, like, kinda builds that momentum. Right?
But then you think you kinda, like, get
really high up on hacker views and everything
is easy, but, you know, it kinda just
kinda gives you a little bit of, like,
tailwind in the moment, but then you kinda,
like, get do it for it. But at
the end of the day, that's kinda, like,
the the long story almost. Right? And and
since we have done a lot of more
intricate things of, like, making sure that, you
know, we have much broader compatibility and move
away from the alpha stage, and I think
the core runme is, like, a lot know,
it's not even better anymore. It's, like, fairly
stable. Right? And and but we keep layering
things on top of it. So that's kinda,
like, you know, the story there, and runme
is sort of the the technology,
the open source project, Apache
two license. And what we're trying to do
at Stateful is then, you know, like, pull
the collaboration layer around it so that, you
know, if you run commands, they fail.
I mean, it happens. Right? I mean, entropy
is a problem. Right? The universe is not
regular. It expands.
And especially when you're working with, like, remotes,
clouds,
you know, there's, like from credentials to,
you know, the Internet being under the weather.
Right? Just things that you can't control. And
what we think is a is an another
clap to gap to close before we make,
you know, something like Terraform fully deterministic is
to just make it easier to escalate issues
instead of, like, you know, getting on a
Zoom call, screen sharing,
or exchanging screenshots.
Right? Like, why can't we not have a
high fidelity bug report with one click? Right?
And that's kinda a little bit like what
Stateful is for and then, you know, doing
that in a secure way where you can
share with the team and you have all
the controls on visibility and and and sharing
and all that sort of stuff. Yeah. And
that's kinda like, you know, we're really early
on there. If anybody's interested in that, please
let me know.
You can go on stateful.com, sign up for
it, try it out. But if you at
the core of your runme.
Nice.
Alright. Thank you for sharing all of that
history and context there. And I think it's
time to get some fingers onto keyboards and
show people how runme works. So
with that, let's pop over.
Mhmm.
Here.
So you've already said the website is runme.dev.
So you can go here and get started.
We're gonna go to the getting started page.
And I guess we'll show the CLI and
the Versus Code extension
just so people get an understanding of what
that, you know, what the first ten minutes
in front of me is like.
Well, we start with it. I don't know.
What would you normally start with when you
show people it? Versus code or the CLI?
I mean, you know, it kinda probably depends
on the use case. So, I mean, like,
since you're driving and and and, you know,
you you have used runme before and you
put in this in a particular way, I'll
probably let you choose. Because I think, you
know, there's, like, probably different use cases how
you would arrive at runme,
and
that kinda picks your journey.
Yeah. I'm gonna start with the CLI just
because
I think it's where I'm more comfortable.
Mhmm. And then we could layer you know,
I I always feel like the Versus Code
extension is like that value add, but it's
not it's not my bread and butter. The
CLI is my bread and butter. So we're
gonna start So
people could just install this. It's
painless for most people, not painless for me.
You can install You're you're a next OS
user. Right? So caveat here. Yeah. It's painful
for me because I'm on Nexus.
But,
you know, things are getting better.
So you can install the CLI. Brew is
probably the way that most of you are
gonna wanna get ahold of this. That's fine.
Just brew install runme. There is the Windows
one.
Yeah. I mean, we're not gonna go over
the installation. It's pretty painless. I think that
installing software is pretty much a solved problem
these days, except for Next.
Know
solving that. Well, yeah. I'm not batching on
Next. Next is the best way to install
software. However,
the version of runme on the Next packages,
which is really, really old
and I did update it, but it's not
been merged yet. So alright.
But either way, we get oh, I'm in
a directory with stuff. Let's go away from
that.
If we run runme, it's just telling us
there's nothing here. So we could do runme
help.
And we can see the kind of main
invocation points here. There's the two a. You
can run individual commands and so forth. But
it all starts with the readme.
And I think
I'm not gonna say, you know, markdown is
a better purpose anymore. It's what we have.
So we'll just create a very simple readme.
I'm
gonna keep it really simple. I hope that's
alright with you.
Yeah. Yeah. Like, I mean, maybe I'll give
you a little context while you're typing. Like,
this is a fenced code block. Right? And
there's this sort of, like, notion of attributes
inside of fenced code blocks. It's, I think,
part of the extended markdown standard.
And, you know, the commonly, you would put
the language. I mean, that's part of the
standard that you can say, hey. This code
block is shell or JavaScript or Python. Right?
And what we do in runme, we also
lay out other attributes,
you know, on top of that if we
wanna control certain aspects of execution. Right? But
we'll get into that probably further down. But
the main idea is to use those code
blocks when you wanna run code. Right? And
code could be commands or literally JavaScript,
Python, any interpretive language.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I guess what was important here for the
people watching is just it's a standard read
me. We're not actually doing anything
unique here.
This is probably what you're shipping already to
GitHub. GitHub is parsing this. It makes it
visual, but it doesn't make it interactive. And
that's really where runme shines.
And Mhmm. Kat wants some
ASMR
of my keyboard.
This is my precious. I've had this for
a while now, and then I'm not letting
it go.
I know when I'm on a stream, I
should be using, like, my really quiet
normal one, but then I just don't get
it just it doesn't bring me joy. Right?
And it doesn't And also when you're not
talking, people know that you're working. Right? I
mean, it's sort of, like, kinda like when
people, you know, just say Mhmm. Mhmm. And
they're not, you know.
It confirms that you're doing something.
That's that's true. Yeah. But that backs against
you when you're on a call with someone
that's one to one, and I'm looking at
them, but really I'm like, type it out.
Type it Type it So anyway,
let's not go into my terrible working habits.
So if we run runme now,
things change a little bit. We've got a
couple of what it's saying are unnamed tasks.
We'll get into that in a little bit,
but it does allow me to run and
select each of these
like so.
Oh, it doesn't like that. Yeah.
Also, you're on a really old version of
runme three zero.
Oh, I don't know why it did.
I mean, my my guess is, like, that
you you are, like, on an ancient version
music. I I I am. I have downloaded
the newer ones. So this is quite an
old one.
It's probably built by Nick's. Right? Because it
has also has the the Unix epoch at
zero nineteen seventies.
There we go.
Let's just kill it. I think it's it's
whenever I use comma, I'm not gonna do
that anymore. That's a horrible next thing that
people don't care about anyway. So we'll skip
over.
Let's modify our readme. So we've got unnamed
tasks. So
by default
and I think this is really powerful for
the people that are watching, like, if you
just have a repository with readmes, with code
blocks, those just work right out the gate.
There's nothing that you need to do.
But we do have the ability to annotate
this. And I this this is where I
got
happy
and confused
with runme,
but in a a nice way, not a
bad way.
Let's just call this echo.
So I didn't know you could do this.
And I says, I don't know if this
is spec compliant markdown or if that spec
is evolving.
If I mean, I don't know if people
have runme or trying to push forward that
spec. Is it a dead spec? Maybe you
can share a better context. But what are
we doing here with this little code block?
Yeah.
Right. So the so the the fence code
block and I and I you know, like,
it's kinda hard to piece a little bit
together historically because, like, there's not, like, one
authority that, like, hands down the markdown standard.
It's a little bit like how the web
works.
And, so the fence code block, I think,
was introduced because the previous notion of a
code block didn't have any annotations,
any attributes.
Right? So the idea with defense code block
was to first encode what language it's in.
And
what we've what I have noticed is that
Jupiter
as well as some other I think Jupiter
mostly,
but also Google and a couple of other
markdown based tools,
they use this
these attributes. Right? So now where you where
you have name echo, it's a JSON encoded,
you know, like, sort of payload in there
that most almost every I think, like, it
might actually be part of the standard.
Will it like, every renderer will ignore. Right?
So if you render it in in Versus
Code or in in GitHub,
it will just not appear. Right?
However, you know, the renderer inside of GitHub
will obviously parse that it's shell and then
sometimes apply some syntax highlighting. Right? What what
is sort of a nice side effect is
that these attributes then can optionally be used
by any form of, like, you know, markdown
processor,
you know, you well, that's a renderer or,
like, something that we do where we transform
it into a different representation, which is a
notebook.
You can,
you know, insert certain attributes that,
you know our metadata, essentially. Right? Like, you
you don't wanna, like, you know you know,
soil your code with
some extra information that really, like, you know,
just confuses whoever is the consumer, the reader
of it. So it gives you the ability
to, like, in encode, you know, metadata that
then, you know, informs how the downstream processing
works. Right?
What you've currently done is you've given the
code block a name.
Yeah. And that that's what like I said,
that's one of the things that I really
like because I played with a lot of
tools to try to make documentation 11. And
what they they tend to do is, like,
enforce some sort of hierarchy for headings or
comments within
the code block. Right. And and I feel
We don't wanna do that. I don't want
to I I feel like that's it's pollution.
Right? It's it's detracting from the value of
the documentation because developers are what actually see
this.
And what I loved and don't expect with
us,
well, JSON payload after the language is that
it is stripped out by GitHub renderer, etcetera.
It doesn't it doesn't sophisticate what I'm trying
to tell anyone looking at documentation that they
haven't come across runme yet. Right. So yeah.
And what what we've done is, like, we
we default to JSON, but if you could
also use
essentially, like, HTML attributes.
You know? It's, like, literally pretend like it's
an attribute of an HTML tag. I think
that's what the initial spec has. You you
still have to do the
the the curly braces. And,
actually, it doesn't do it doesn't do quotes.
Right? And by the way, you don't have
to do the the quotes on the on
the beginning and the end.
A what?
Yeah. So this will work. Yeah. And, yeah,
and and this will work too. So, you
know, like, what we've noticed is that the
the spec allows you to, like, use your
your custom form of encoding, and we default
to JSON because it's just a little it's
more readable.
I have, however, noticed that Google doesn't like
it, so we'll probably just continue.
Like, when we when we parse it, we'll
probably write it back in the way we
parsed it instead of always forcing in JSON,
which is what currently happens. But, yes, that
should work.
Alright. God. I didn't know that. That's pretty
cool. Let's see what happens if we run
I mean, if if you're on you know,
the the the one thing I will say
is the caveat might be that you're on
three zero two. Your old version might be
too old.
No. It's it's picked it up. We've got
echo and we've got Oh, yeah. Right. We've
got really
alright. Nice. Let's I'm not won't bother running
those again because those are pretty dull and
we've already seen this now. So let's remove
this.
But obviously, our code blocks can get quite
chunky.
So let's say we wanna do an l
s, a p s. I know these are
horribly contrived commands, but we'll
do bash dash c echo
hello.
Eventually get back down to hello world.
So, yeah, not realistic.
However,
when we're presented with this, one of the
things that I also really like about this
product is that we have the space expand
command, which will actually drop down and show
me everything that I am going to run.
And it's just such a simple thing, but
very, very cool.
And we can run that, and we get
hello, which is nice. Yep. And to to
add and I I can maybe show this
later in the newer version, we will also
if there's a preceding paragraph,
we will show a a sort of teaser
of that paragraph after the commands.
So it it kinda, like, contextualizes.
You know, if it says echo, it could
say, like, you know, prince hello world. Right?
I mean, it probably doesn't need that form
of documentation because it's obvious, but, like, with
more complex commands or something like
make deploy,
right, you might wanna, like, add what it
actually deploys. Right? And You mean like this?
And it
yeah. Like, if you have a preceding paragraph.
So if you wrote just like
yeah. Exactly.
But you have to be on a on
a later version
for that to be displayed.
I have one.
That does not look like a latest version
to me.
I I think, you know, like, your your
build system, your next probably, like, is tricking
you.
Alright. Well, I'll let you show the cool
stuff then. I'll I'll just show what I
can. But, you know, the fundamentals are not
different. Right? It's we we've just done a
little bit more, you know, like, work on
refining the the user experience.
Yeah. Someone's
at my door, but I'm gonna just ignore
that.
Now something that I only discovered yesterday,
and I promise you, I've been using runme
for weeks, is that you get to runme
list, which just throws them out like that.
So and there's that description, which is cool.
Right. Right. And that description is basically then
also showing up in the in the t
y. It's the it's the same idea.
One thing I I do wanna mention because
I think you have pointed out, like, a
very important feature is
naming code blocks.
By default, the code blocks are not named.
They are being hidden. And and the idea
here is kinda, like, to create a public
interface in the CLI.
So, like, you you the ones that you
name,
you're basically exporting.
You know, if you're a program on the
export function
where you make it public, you oftentimes, you
know, like, mark that as, like, this is
my public interface.
So it's leaned, like, you know, on that
same idea that you can give an entry
point that is more narrowed down. Right? So
that that you don't overwhelm,
you know, people that come to your readme,
to your documentation
with all the code blocks that are possibly
available. Right?
Yeah.
Cool.
Let's run help. So
the I mean, I guess we should show
Versus code. Right? But what we've essentially shown
is the interactive two, which allows us to
select commands.
We've done less and we've done run.
There's the format to a canonical
format, which I've never run before. I don't
know what that does, so maybe we can
get into that.
And you offer shell completion, which I didn't
know either. So,
I mean, my life could be a lot
easier even after this session, which I'm already
excited about. So. Well, you know, it's all
about education. Right? So we all learn, and
I learn from this too.
Mhmm.
Yeah. So if you wanted want me to
quickly say a word on format.
So format is essentially,
you know, it prices all your markdown,
sort of, like, runs it, you know, like,
ingested into an abstract syntax tree and then
renders it from there. So what what will
happen is, you know, for example, if you
had,
you know, irregulars
in, like, how, you know, your
attributes are, you know, encoded in your fence
code blocks, it will normalize that to all
JSON. Right? So it's it's basically almost kinda
like, you know, take take an existing markdown
code base,
and then you can run it through a
c deserialization and a serialization step and write
it back.
And what that will do, especially when you
get started on runme, is, like, runme is
really like, we spend a lot of time
making it so that we change your markdown
minimally,
but there are certain things that people do
in markdown that is really difficult parse into
a linear representation like a notebook and then
reconstruct. And, for example, like, what lists inside
of, like, on what are lists inside of
and then having code blocks inside of that
is just a little difficult. Right? I mean,
like, you know, preserving that information and then
reconstructing it, especially, you know, since you also
can edit notebooks.
Right? So, you know, this is a long
way of saying we kinda, like, get ahead.
You can run the command. You could do
that the first thing if you, like, deciding
to implement this in your repo. And then
the diffs that come after are, like, extra
minimal. Right? Because they're, like, really just the
edits that you're making and not some sort
of, like just because more you know, runme
is slightly opinionated in the way it run
writes markdown.
Obviously, you know, we try to be as
accommodating as possible within, like, those constraints. Right?
And that's what the format command is for.
Ah, nice.
Alright. Let's do one more thing on the
the CLI and then we'll pop this open
in Versus Code. So now that we know
from your chat earlier on that the original
name was r d m r d m
e. Right? Mhmm. Yes.
Know,
open source projects particularly, they like to have
a readme that is for users of the
project. Right? And then, typically, you'd have some
sort of contributing
dot m d,
which could have more documentation.
So I just wanna show that this works
across multiple files and directories and whatever. So
contributing,
and I'll name it as well.
Do I need the braces for this format?
Yep. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. That's that's just to
terminate the
all the attributes. Right?
And I see it.
Oh, come on, New Shell. You don't like
dash p?
That was a horrible way to do it,
but it it'll work. And I'll call that.
I mean, the markdown name, as far as
I know, doesn't actually mean anything, so I'm
gonna call it arbitrary.
And then we'll have another shell.
And then we'll talk about other things besides
shell because I don't know the answer to
that and I am curious. So Mhmm. We'll
call this nest ed.
It's just as echo nested. Okay. So we've
got a contributing file. We've got a deeply
nested world dot m d. All our tasks
are named. We run this
and we have nested here and contrib here.
So it's like it scans
everything below my current directory, and I think
please correct me if I'm wrong. If we're
in a GET repository, it scans the entire
repository
for tasks. Right? Correct. Yeah.
So so the way it works, it will
it will honor your git ignore
just so, you know, like, if you, for
example, have, like,
vendors like, node modules, right, like, the same
directory, it will skip all of those.
But, yeah, we'll traverse the whole tree and
then and then identify markdown files,
parse them all, and then and then glob
them, so, you know, so to speak, together.
But then also filter out all the unnamed
task unless you hit you right now. Right?
And but I I don't think you probably
I don't know how to do Yeah. Yeah.
So it's it's the same thing. But that
way, you know, you kinda and and you're
right. If you're, like if you're deeper down
in the directory, it will actually walk up
and check if it's a git repository.
And that's this is behavior that you can
change, and I know that you you opinionated
about them. I I agree in mono repos.
That makes sense.
But the idea really is for you to
make it a no brainer
to run,
you know, like, important commands irrespective of where
you are. Right? Even if you do runme
run and then specify the name, it will
run from any directory. It will always anchor
the current working directory based on where the
file is. Right? So that's just for convenience
so you don't get, like, lost in in
the directory tree.
Alright.
Okay. So I hadn't really appreciated
that. So now I'm curious what happens and
sorry. I'm gonna go off track for just
a minute. Right? So
let's have echo.
We'll call this echo button nested, and I'm
gonna give it the same name.
How does it handle that then? Does it
does the anchoring to the
this directory?
Yeah. So
when you have
well, so that this you know, this old
version, so I'm not entirely sure. Oh, in
three point zero. But what will happen is,
like, if you have you know, if you
use a TOI and you have two
tasks that have the same name, both of
them will show up. They will just have,
their file that's associated with is always next
to it. If you do it runme run,
it will just say, like, hey. I found
two. Pick the one you want.
Okay. Yeah. So
from here, we can select the echo that
we want. Mhmm. And then from If you
did run me run me run and then
type echo, I think it should, you know,
prompt you to yeah. Nice.
Okay.
Very cool.
Now
I've not tried this before and I don't
know if this is a dead end, but
I'm gonna ask. Does
runme support
extra languages on the Fence code block?
Can I do
Python?
You you should be able to. Again, caveat
is, like, I don't know if it will
work with the three point o version.
Because, like, that's, like, you know, we have
three eight now.
We did release a feature that we call
sheeting. Right? I like this leaned on
how
the shell handles it. So what we do
is, like, when you use Python, JavaScript, anything
that's interpreted,
we we we basically look for a binary.
Right? And we we kinda have a map
mapping list there where, you for Python, we
look for binary called Python three. Right? And
then if we don't find that, we look
for Python two. Right?
And then, yeah, for for Dino, use Dino.
You can also do TS for TypeScript, and
then we will attempt
the different
TypeScript run times. Right? Ah.
Do I have Python?
No. I had Dano. Alright. That'll do.
Yeah. But I think you might be
too many releases behind. But, like, you know,
may maybe just try and see what happens.
Yeah. Like, think you're too many Oh, I
did name them. That's what it is.
Oh, okay. Cool. If I show unnamed now
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got them. Okay.
There's demo. Deno log demo. And
this is the Python one. So
ah. Yeah. Okay. It it will it will
work in in 3.8.
But, like, in a in a in a
much more like, 03/30 is old.
I think we're talking, like, you know, like,
almost a year old.
Yeah. Sorry for my my very old version.
But, you know It's it's okay. I I'll
let you stick your hands on your keyboard
very, very soon. I will take I was
gonna say I I can show that. But
yeah. So so, you know, just to close
the loop there,
there's a default mapping list. Right? And it
it it looks in your path, but there's
also, an attribute. And it's easier to do
this in Versus Code because you can kinda
get a little list of them where you
can set the custom interpreter. Right? So if
you had
some some language,
you know, like, that you created yourself,
you can associate a cell with that interpreter,
and it will just run it with using
your custom interpreter.
Alright. Well, I have opened in Versus Code.
So this is the the same readme that
we were working
against. Right? So
So if you hit the play button on
Deno
I'm not sure if Deno works. You might
have to do TypeScript.
Because, like, at the end of the day,
Dino is TypeScript.
I know that Dino.log is the Dino flavor
of, I guess, TypeScript you could call it.
So, yeah, that probably won't work.
Alright. So,
okay, let's start with this simple example. Right?
Just and then we'll talk about how we
configure tasks. So Mhmm. This
one here is a standard
shell exec. We had to play but
What is that? What have I done? Oh,
I know what this is. This is me.
Sorry.
Not only am I running next, but I
use new shell.
Oh,
are you it's it's it's actually dashes, not,
you know, like, not the way you turn
it from there. Yeah.
Let's see.
Rust backtrace. Why is it running Rust?
That's crashing my shell now.
I should I I should just stop playing
with new tools. That's that's the problem.
Yeah. I mean, the the problem with with
broad compatible
shell support is that if they're not, like,
POSIX and and and sort of Unix compatible,
like, 100%, it's it's you know, you really,
like, run into all the the corner cases.
Yeah. Is it shell at the top? That
should be right. Yeah. That's right. Yeah. I
felt like it did. Also looks like it's
trying to execute it. Yeah. Because, like,
this all looks right, but,
yeah, that does not look right.
Yeah. Let's just say it's my fault. So
I'm not Yeah. I mean, I don't wanna,
you know, blame anybody.
Oh, this is I think this is using
his own downloaded version,
which again, I'm on Nexus. So there's always
a world of hurt there. Why don't we
jump over to your screen share and you
can actually
and I'll just shut down my computer and
go to bed and you can take over.
I could show the happy path. Yeah. To
to be fair, it's it's it's a lot
happier, you know, if you if you don't
have a a whole lot of custom
and and new tools. So I'll share. Right?
Yeah. Please. Let's see.
I'm just gonna do entire screen.
So I'm gonna
is that visible?
It will be in just a moment. I'm
gonna swap this out.
And, yeah, I can see your Versus code.
Take it away, man.
Cool. Alright. So maybe I'll I'll kinda, like,
pick up where you left off. Right?
So,
you know, for example,
font mailer, you can encode in TOML. You
don't have to use
YAML.
You know? Like, so we we kinda, like,
try to be broadly compatible.
But in this case here,
you know, I'm using Python. Right? And,
you know, like, obviously, you can write this
over here or you can just select you
can change the whatever language you are
using here.
Then, you know, we'll just change it for
you, right, because it serializes. But, obviously, this
is not JavaScript. It's Python. And
I think what you were trying to do
is
run runme, and and this is the the
latest, you know, 3.83,
which has the the documentation
kinda teased here. Right?
If you would like to find out more,
yada yada. But, essentially, you you know, that
way you can kinda contextualize what the commands
actually does. Because in lot of ways, write,
install this thing and then run this step
and run this step. And in the CLI,
you, you know, your space constraints, but, like,
it still helps you understand what's actually going
on. Right?
So now if I go and
run this escape Confluence step, right, which is
Python,
it will just run Python.
So it eventually just executes this here. Right?
And
for what it's worth,
it does that for, like,
all of the interpreted languages. If you need
a binary or a jar of some sort,
you probably have to build it first anyways,
and then you can just run the binary.
Right? So you just run it as a
command.
What else did we show that didn't work?
Just so I closed the loop on it.
So let's see. One thing that, like, you
know, is also kinda important to understand or,
like, helpful to understand is, again,
you know, we scan the whole directory,
so it doesn't really matter where you are.
But what does matter is
the proximity where you are on the directory
tree, so the sorting will be different. Right?
So the the idea is, like, the the
markdown files that are closer to you, right,
in this case, I have a docs folder.
Right?
When I'm in the in the directory here,
they will show up
first. Right? And then, you know, as you
can see here, there's a, you know, dot
dot readme.
So it traverses out of the directory. Right?
The idea here being is, like, the closer
you are to the markdown file, the more
interested you probably are in the tasks that
can you know, are contained inside of it.
Right?
So there's a lot of, like, kinda, like,
you know, thought that we put into that.
Not sure if that resonates. If it doesn't,
you know, please create a GitHub issue.
I would love to hear, you know, why
and why not.
So
so yeah. So the you know, this is
kind of a terminal experience, and and David's
done a a a great job showing that
off.
But,
you know, once you get into the notebook,
the other things we can do. Right? And
the reason why that is because we're not
constrained to a character interface.
So I'm not gonna go through through installing
all these prerequisites because I've already done that.
But
a thing that we can do is, like,
inline cloud resources. Right? So instead of, like,
some sort of esoteric command with, like, lots
of command options, you can literally copy and
paste the URL. Right? So if I go
on here and open that, I get my
runme c I clusters in my Google console,
and you can obviously do the same thing
for AWS.
But when you hit the play button, it
will expand
that UI right into your notebook. Right? What?
And I didn't know that. Yeah. Well, you
know, that's why we're here.
And
and so another another useful feature that we
found is that you can kinda, you know,
create these sort of, like, session carbon copies
of what you're doing.
And in fact, even in the session file,
we will we will render the underlying
API's,
you know, response. Right? So if you're recording
yourself,
you in the markdown file, right, you might
not get the render UI, but you still
know what was being displayed. Right? So we
kinda, like, really try to, like, deliver
on this concept of, like, being able to
create audio facts of what you're doing. Right?
If you wanna share them, that's up to
you. Right? But, like, sometimes it even helps
just having them, you know, be recorded so
you can go back later and see, hey.
What did I do? Or what was the
thing at the time when I ran it?
Right? Yeah. That's entropy.
That is so cool.
And, you know, like, another thing you can
do is click on it and insert another
cell.
And
in in this case, since I'm looking at
a Kubernetes cluster
list, right, it will give me the Kubernetes
cluster details. Right? So I clicked on cluster
two because it's the only one that has
nodes.
And then, know, like, you you essentially get
a little UI here,
that kinda traverses into it. Right? So you
have all the list of clusters and the
clusters,
list of nodes,
and you can even go all the way
into
the VM level. Right?
And we're we're trying to expand that library
of available,
you know, like,
cloud resources in the notebooks.
Essentially, what this really is is a web
component, which is also open standard. We're basically
just building custom vendors for that. And the
notebook knows how to associate, you know, these
these resources.
Is that using the g cloud command behind
the scenes to get this information and then
render it? Yeah. Behind the scenes, it uses
the SDK,
which, you know, yeah, which but which is
also sensitive and and and, you know, tuned
to pick up on your environment. So so
it's it's it's essentially using the same tool
chain. So if you like, I'm currently authenticating
with my account,
so that way it knows what, you know,
like, how to authenticate against the APIs and
what authorization I have.
So it's all transparent in that way.
Nice.
And, you know, it works for AWS too.
We're still you know, this is kinda like
a lot of legwork involved. You're building out
these UIs.
But, you know, like, you know, in a
in a in a ideal world, we would
have that for all of GCP, for all
of AWS, for all of Azure. Right? And
it's sort of the work in progress that
we're trying to
churn through. Right?
Another thing is when you turn off interactive
the interactive flag here,
essentially, what this does I mean, we're gonna
show it over here because it kinda, like,
brings it back to
the
markdown representation.
It sets the attribute to, you know, true
or false. Right? And the
difference here is, like, interactive is really just
like, is this a terminal, or is it
some is it something else? Right? Is the
output that I'm expecting a terminal?
It will just render a terminal. Right? But
if, for example, you are curling an image,
right,
it's not you know, if you if you
run it internally, you get a binary block.
It looks a little bit like what you
saw on David when in David's terminal when
this when this Nick's crashed.
But, you know, like, the notebook knows how
to, like, render images. It knows how to
render CSV files. Right? So what it does
here is, like, it just renders the image.
Right?
And it works kinda like me similarly how
these components here work, these cloud resources where,
you know, we we try to be smart
about detecting what MIME type it has and
then render it accordingly. Right? And this is
kinda like where you're starting to, obviously, from
a from a UI standpoint, break out of
a terminal.
But, you know, the cool thing is at
the end of the day, people can still
run this in the terminal. Right? And you
can still and we haven't like, I still
have to actually close out that ticket. If
you ran on a terminal, it could pop
you into a browser. Right? So I think
the important thing that we wanted to do
here is bring the UI into the notebook,
but don't close the door behind us for
people that don't wanna use a notebook, right,
which is, for example, a terminal.
And, you know, so it it remains functional.
Right? Because at the end of the day,
you know, I'm just opening a URL and
you get your cloud console over here. Right?
So this sort of concept is is, like,
you know, somewhat exclusive to the notebook, but
for obvious reasons because we're not in the
character interface. Yeah.
Another thing that is is worth mentioning is,
you know, like, not having the sort of
clutter of, like, how do I get the
project name,
you know, to be entered by the user?
You know, like, now you could write some
sales script and do some gum and and,
you know, like, STD. What is it called?
The read command and the terminal and all
that. But, like, a design principle that we
have in runme is it should look like
documentation.
You know? Like, we shouldn't have the imperative
steps how to enter the project name that
just caught us in documentation because it doesn't
add anything
to what I'm currently doing. Right? So when
I run this,
it will actually prompt me. Right? So I
can say, like, runme c I. Right? Where,
if you put quotes on it, it will
use it as a default value. Right? So
I can just confirm it.
Right? So that way, you know, like, again,
if you're in the terminal, you can still
copy and paste it. In fact, if I
run this in the terminal,
it will also ask me. Right?
I might have to do some digging here
because, like, I didn't give this a name.
But anytime you see an export statement on
it, it will ask you,
see how it does this here? Enter your
project ID runme CI.
Right? Yeah. That's slick.
Yeah. So the idea is to, like you
know, that way you can actually produce generic
documentation
but not make it so generic that everybody
has to reverse engineer it. Right?
And another cool thing that we do is
once this is set,
we don't ask again. Right? So if I
rerun this, the values are known, but you
can always say, like, prompt for input anyways,
and then it will reask you. Right?
And another thing that should work in here,
so I can see my cursor.
Runme.
Yep. Is, once the value is also known,
the terminal and the notebook share
the environments,
which, you know, there's a lot of engineering
effort that went into that. So it also
doesn't ask you. So, essentially,
the terminal ends,
the notebook share a managed environment, right, that
sort of transcends, you know, your terminal session.
So you when you complete steps in here,
you can kinda pick up on them in
the terminal and vice versa.
That is, like, currently, you know, specific to
Versus Code because we really use the the
way, you know, the terminal is integrated into
Versus Code to make that happen because it's
not trivial
to cross boundaries. Right?
And, yeah, at the end of the day,
I think it was a cluster two,
if I'm not mistaken.
Yes.
You know, you can you can essentially just,
you know, see if any parts are running.
Right?
Another thing that we do in the UI
here is when you set the background flag,
we don't block the notebook. Right? It it
just drops you into a background watcher.
And that one, you can also
can you know, you can watch down here
too. So we multiplex the terminal.
And, you know, I can apply, for example,
a YAML file or install a Helm chart
or
whatever it is. Right? And you you could
even, like, move on and just keep an
eye on it here, right, because the terminal
is multiplexed.
And
yeah. So
those are kinda, like just kind of the
bread and butter of the notebook.
Sort of the What does the
fork button do?
Yeah. So the fork button is brand new
and, like, you have to turn on version
two.
Let me see if I have that turned
on here. Like, maybe let's do something down
here.
So echo
my name.
Right? So when I run this,
of course, my name is a is a
brand new variable, you know, environment
variable I made up. So what you can
do now is you can hit the fork
button.
Right? You could do something like
I did this before. My dog Luna, right,
is my name. And so the fork button,
the idea is you fork the terminal session.
Right? And then you can roll it up
again. Right? So I inherit the environment of
the notebook in this terminal at the time
of you know, when I hit the fork
button. So if I had you know, actually,
if I do
what is it?
Just hop back for a hot second.
I'm just gonna have to see cluster name.
Right?
This should be set here. No. It's not.
Okay.
The reason why that is this gives me
right now. But, essentially, the idea then is,
like, if you can exit this terminal,
and now when I run this,
you know, like so when I roll it
up, it will then, you know, close the
terminal and update all the environment variables with
whatever I set them or mutated them in
the terminal session.
Another thing that you can do is
if you don't like clicking around here and,
like, do use
the the notebook editor,
you can also hit the forward button and
then just go about your ways. Right?
Do your thing and then type save,
and then it will
grab the whole session and and and and,
essentially, like, hoist it into
into the notebook. So you can, you know,
you can essentially start editing. Right? And what
we wanna do here, and this is a
lot of work because we have to build
yet another, you know, abstract syntax tree, is
to parse the the sequence of characters and
then and then chop it up into a
notebook for you. But
the idea here is to make authoring easier.
Right? So That's neat. Yeah. Long I like
that. You know, long story short is, like,
you fork the notebook on two ways. Right?
The actual content of it, but also the
environment.
And then whether you exit it with exit
or save. So save will roll up the
environment,
and save will roll up the environment in
literally the session and and copy it into
a into a cell.
So see
the session, is that what those extra
readme fail like, markdown fails are? You can
see you've got two cloud files and two
three
cloud files and two gapless.
See how I have the I have the
auto save on? This is like, you know,
like,
when we when we serialize, you know, what's
in this file here, right, when we go
in here,
and this is the notebook diff view, but
you can always do the file diff view.
You know, see how
this has now changed, and it has
all the stuff
inside of the cell. So when you when
you hit save,
it will only serialize input cells. It will
ignore output cells. Right? Because the idea is,
like, documentation is only, you know, relevant to
you for the inputs. You create your own
outputs. Right?
When you turn on auto save, it will
create a separate file that is really, like,
a carbon copy of what
the inputs are, but it also includes the
outputs.
And it does that per session. So if
I hit the reset session button here
and then I save again, you know, I
get a brand new file. And Okay.
And, you know so the idea here is,
you know, like, I did all of this
and, you know, maybe I ran out of
disco. My my next door has a problem,
and and then I can go on my
session output and I can say generate a
gist,
log in to to GitHub, and then, you
know, I have a secure gist here. Secure
in the way that it's not listed. You
know, everybody can access it if they have
the URL.
But I could send that over to you.
Right? So it kinda, like, just makes the
cuts out the steps it takes to,
you know, like, copy and paste, do screenshots,
that sort of stuff.
Yeah. I can imagine this would be really
helpful, like, if you're say someone's play move
runme and they have a problem, they can
just create a notebook, guess that, and then
pop it into the issue.
Right? And and, you know, like, the idea
really is to sometimes even give people a
readme as sort of a starting point to
platform them. Right? Like, you know, use your
cluster. Here are the common things that you
do, and here's a little bit of a
troubleshooting section.
And if you can't troubleshoot yourself, just run
all the cells and then and then, you
know, gist it. Right?
This is also where we have, you know,
like, a stateful as a product come in.
I can log in with my stateful accounts
over here.
And
and, essentially, then instead of, like, creating gist,
pump that into our platform, and then you
get all the features of sharing it with
the team, posting into Slack,
that sort of stuff. But, yeah, it really
is sort of for the troubleshooting.
I mean, troubleshooting and also recording what you
did scenario. Right? Because sometimes you wanna, I
don't know. Like, something on a on a
server where you are, MRF, you
know, some
I I don't know. Like, something that you
wanna, like, okay. I wanna have an artifact
of that when it happened and what happens.
Right? Because it's a high stakes task.
Yeah.
And I'm I'm editing the which I shouldn't
be doing the
I mean, you can. Right? You can you
can redact and then create a
a gist of it.
One thing that I quickly wanna show before
I hop on to another
sort of features,
What I find need is, like, for VMs,
for example, we don't just give you the
resource, but you can, you know, click on
the SSH button here, it will literally drop
you into an SSH session to the VM.
So that's that's kinda neat. Right?
Because it kinda, like, literally, like, I'm on
the node of my Kubernetes cluster. I think
I clicked. Right? Or did I use instance
Nided instance, but I could, you know, just
h SSH into cluster two's node here
with one click and,
I don't know, do some sort of, like,
you know, analysis work and then, like, hop
out and and be done with it. Right?
And it all records in my session file
too.
But you said that you support AWS and
GCP for that. Right? That that that's a
color feature. I hadn't seen that. I love
it. Do you plan to do the same
for Kubernetes to the point if I run
get pods, can I then just click show
me logs of this pod? Because that would
be a really cool feature.
Yeah. I mean, like, you know, all of
this stuff is very extensible. I mean, we
did a a integration with Dagger that, like,
essentially uses the CLI button layers, you know,
sort of actions on top that, you know,
conceivably, you could also, if you, for example,
build a directory
or build into a file. A directory is
probably a better example, could then actually list,
you know, directory and the files inside of
it. And then you could maybe even have
a button that then opens the file in
in another tab.
So
yeah. That's I mean, yes. Yeah. Anything
is possible. Yeah. More time, more people, more
hours. Like, that's Right. What it boils down
to. So Exactly. And, you know, like, another
thing that we have, we have a few
GitHub workflows that we trigger manually.
So this is kinda neat because when you're
contributing MD, we have a release flow and
then, you know, if I mean, not not
all of our pipelines run. There's you know,
most of them run on push,
but the release one, we we just dispatch
a workflow.
So
this is, I think, a test no. It's
actually the live repo, but I I can
build a a prerelease version. That's not gonna
hurt anybody.
But this will literally, like, kick off
a GitHub workflow.
And if I open it over here, you
know, you'll see it just this is your
familiar UI.
Are these integrations documented?
Because I I don't know how I missed
this. Like, do you list where these are?
Yeah. There is an integration section. So I
think cloud renderers,
AWS,
Cloud Run, Cloud Platform. Yeah. And yeah. Yeah.
There there yeah. Maybe a little hidden away
here. For example, Dagger is in here too.
And, yeah, we've there's also a lot to
get to, right, which is kinda, like, I
think, part of the problem, which is also
why I'm moving on because there's a lot
to get to.
So so the other killer feature in my
mind is, like, if you have a diverse
team, including people like Mix and some Windows
users,
you can actually peer your notebooks and your
documentation with, like, what I call an ops
container,
which is literally just a a fancy way
of saying a dev container.
But, like, since you you are more
operating software and not developing software, I like
calling it ops container.
So what I just did is my repo
here, I open up inside of the container.
And what that will do is, like, I
have some generic container on it right now,
but you could literally have any container image
running behind it. I think this just has
a bull's eye. Like, what is that? Debian,
I think. Yeah. Debian. Linux.
Yeah.
And what's cool about it is now you
could go and lock in your dependencies,
your system dependencies. Right? Like, the kubectl version,
the the Terraform that you're using down to
the patch version and distribute the image and
just pin your image to this repo, and
everybody always has the same dependencies. Right? There's
no excuse
for the documentation not to work because the
upstream system dependencies are not met. Right? And
this is obviously kinda like an advanced feature.
Right? Like, I think oftentimes documentation plan doesn't
work because it's actually just long.
But there's another side to that coin, right,
where if your documentation is right, your system
dependencies might not be missed. Right? And and
this is just kinda like a fantastic way
to just bake it into it. Right?
And then distribute your repo like usual,
you know, and you can manage all of
your changes to your documentation through
pull request, you know, a Git workflow.
And
but everybody can, you know, essentially have a
reproducible environment
and run the same stuff. Right? And without
having to, you know, sacrifice,
you know, the the the sort of comfort
of, like, having the same notebook UI because,
like, there is really no difference when you
look at it. Right? It says, like, I'm
running in a in a dev container. Right?
If I reopen this locally again
and I run the same cells, it will
say, like,
I'm running locally because I am running locally.
Right?
So
that's one way of, like, you know, sharing
that with your team. And if you wanted
to get real fancy,
you could even I'm not sure if my
VM is up and running. But you can
also attach your Versus codes to a
remote
server using SSH.
So you maintain the same notebook UI locally,
but you are in fact running against,
you know, a jump host, for example.
And you could do the same thing with
code spaces
or get pod or any of those things.
Let me just open something.
And, you know, you basically have the same
UI, but, like, the subtle difference is, like,
now I'm actually on a remote host, and
you'll probably depending on how far away you
are from I think this runs on the
East Coast. You get a little bit of
latency. Right? But you have the same
you know, more or less the same
tools, the same environment,
but it runs remotely now. But my Chrome,
you know, what I'm seeing is they hold
the same. Right? And I get the same
features.
Nothing really changes, but it it's sort of
portable in the way that, like, we had
a computer and made a memory. It's almost,
you know, indistinguishable,
right, unless you look for the details here.
Nice.
Yeah.
And
to kinda close the loop, right, because, you
know, it's upstream dependencies,
like, the system dependencies,
you know, credentials,
and then
documentation workflow and task being right, something that
we're working on that's still
literally actively being worked on that I wanna
release soon is
this managed environment score.
We we we really wanna create way of
making it visible. Right? And
when I say visible is, like, also when
you mutate it. So
this sounds a little esoteric, and I should
probably stop using computer science terms. But,
you know, what you can see on the
bottom is, like, what is currently in my
managed environment store. Right? So
when runme starts a new session,
it'll look for dot infile, dot inf local
files, and then load them in your environment.
Right? And it also obviously does it with
your dash or your z shell or c.
One thing that we created, and that's that's
kind of the work in process, is, like,
a simple type system
so that you can describe your how your
environment is supposed to look like,
and it accounts for sensitivities
of variables. Right? So one thing that I'm,
well, you know, somewhat proud of is, like,
I'm not shy to show you my OpenAI
key because it's redacted. Right? So I marked
this as a secret,
and now it's being shown as a secret.
So if I take a screenshot of it,
I don't have to worry about leaking my
secrets. Right?
And
if I, for example,
I could even overwrite, you know, like, values
in this environment story here. Let's say,
allow URL patterns. Right?
One thing that, you know, is also not
obvious, you can when you name a cell,
like, an environment variable,
the content of the cell will actually be
stuck into the like, it will wind up
in the environment. Right? So if I do
something like this
and then run this,
see how the value has changed to one,
two, three, four? Mhmm.
And, you know, so, like, it it it
tracks the values, you know, over time. Right?
So, like, even if you mutate them, it
will change.
Also
I mean, I seeded my environment
using this environment file.
But if I, for example, remove a required
variable, will show me, hey. My database URL
is not set.
So the idea here and I'm still building
this out. We are you know, there are
sort of two
parts to this type system. One is sort
of like a a primitive type that just,
you know, controls the visibility
and whether or not it's required,
sort of a binary
that you need this to run your service,
your repo, your documentation.
And then we'll be layering on top of
that type as validation.
And in in this case,
you know, like, it it understands that database
URL needs to be compliant to a database
URL. Right? So it has to, you know,
actually be a valid database URL, so, like,
a Postgres, for example. Right?
And
what that then will do is, like, if
I, for example, make up some stuff, I
call this Sebastian,
and I reset my environment, it will tell
me
that this is actually not valid.
Unknown database scheme. Right? And
so this environment
this managed environment store,
you know, I almost kinda we wanna get
to a place where you can include and
we'll probably create some sort of CRD for
this.
Right now, we lean it on the examples
file where you essentially annotate it.
You will make it so that you can,
you know, type your environments.
And
that way, when you load into it, you
know what's missing. Right? If you have a
dot in file and it's partial, what's from
an older version, it will show you what
the difference is. It's like, oh, somebody introduced
a new environment there, but you haven't set
that one. Guess what? Your documentation won't work
because you're missing, you know, some core piece
to it. Right?
And,
you know, like, the idea is to specify,
you know, in a in a sort of,
like, well formed way how your environment is
supposed to look like.
And then another layer that we can lay
on top of it that I'm still working
on is that we can also do resolution.
Right? I can go
use your GCP
identity
and, you know, like, go into the GCP
secret manager or use, you know, a cloud
key MS
to either decrypt some stuff or grab them
from a secret manager. I didn't I was
literally about to ask you for that feature
when you showed me the episode there because
I use
GCP secret manager with bare glass secret references.
And I was like, if you could just
detect all of those bare glass secret references
and resolve them with the g cloud CLI,
like,
that would be phenomenal. Like No. That's that's
that's
exactly the plan.
And, you know, you probably get an environment
picker where you click down here.
And, you know, you can say, like, staging
one, staging US, staging Europe, production. And so
so, like, I think, like, it will not
just resolve. It might also prevent accidents because,
like, I remember some company, like, six months
ago posted a postmortem on on Hacker News,
how they accidentally blew their production database away
because somebody had their local environment configured to
point at production without knowing. Right?
And
this is, like, highly programmable.
So, you know, like, what you're seeing here
is really, like, kinda like a UI version
of it, but, like, what's under the hood
is, like, a graph representation of it. So
I can also do the same view in
in the CLI. So I get, like, the
same listing where it's from.
And and, you know, like, the resolution
aspect of it, I still need to build
out, but, like, it's
pretty easy to lay on top of it
once you, you know, once you have a
specification of how your environment has to look
like. And then my my sort of idea
for the resolve
resolver part, and sounds like this would help
you too, is to ideally just use conventions.
Right? Like, you know you know it's a
secret, and then, you know, this looks like
this. If you lower case it, that's the
value is inside of the secret manager using
that project. Right? To kinda, like, make it
really easy and not create yet another, you
know, YAML file, another thing where you have
to then manage your mapping. Right?
But that's all kinda, like, the loosey goosey
still because it's, like, literally inactive development. Right?
Hey. Shit. I want it I want it
today, please. Like, just Yeah. Yeah. Like, I'm
I'm going to. I'm going to. Like, the
thing that I wanna do is I wanna
do a little bit more work to go
from,
you know, the managed environments to a currently
like, you only really ever need to describe,
you know, sort of the critical part of
the environment. Right? But all the other part
of the environment is still in here. Right?
What I wanna do is, like, just make
sure that we showcase how the validation works
a little bit better
because the validation part is also something that
then you can customize. Right? So, essentially, this
database URL, when there will probably be a
bunch of ones that come out of the
box because everybody needs them, but you can
literally also write your own, right, where you
I think I used the validator library, the
Golang one,
and you can you can just,
you know, make up your own. Right? But
the good news is it's gonna be inside
of your repo. Right? And your repo is
collocated with your dependencies. It's collocated with your
documentation. It's collocated with your environment spec.
Right?
And then the resolution can either use your
human identity, right, my GCP identity because I
ran, what was it, g cloud auth login.
But in CI, I can use the same
thing. I just use a workload identity. Right?
So that way,
we get away from doing this thing where
we stick all this information inside of GitHub
or
GitLab.
And then anytime we wanna move from one
CI to the other, we have to go
in and figure out what all these these
variables are here. Right? What's this stuff here?
Right? So, I mean,
call me call me a you know, call
me crazy or, like, maybe you have a
chip on my shoulder, but, like, I think
we're really handing over all of our bargaining
chips to these cloud providers so they can
charge us for locking us in.
If we could just do something like this
and then actually also make the user experience
better because, like, if my environment is incomplete,
the thing will actually yell at me. Right?
And,
you know, there's also, like, a lot of
stuff you could put on top of it.
For example, what I really want is a
little button here that says, like, ping my
database
and make sure I can actually connect to
it. Right?
Like, imagine how how many, like, you know,
how how you don't have to, like, look
for a needle on the haystack. Right? Where
if a base 64 encoded string has a
space at the end. Right? And the base
64 encoding is, like, you know, falling over
and you spend hours of your life trying
to figure out where that problem comes from,
turns out the environment variable is just ever
so slightly wrong. Right?
Yeah. It means you could like, one of
my use cases is which I think you're
gonna be able to support just by everything
that you're building here is, like, you know,
there's a command for deploying to production, but
there's a big note above it saying you
need access to these secrets. And it's like,
you could just have little text saying, hey.
You can run this command. And, like Yeah.
I I did not expect to see this,
and I could not be happier to see
this. This is a fantastic feature.
Yeah. But what what we're trying to with
runme is is and, you know, like, you
kinda, like, wind up wandering off into, like,
little pockets because, like, certain features resonate immediately.
But what we're trying to get to is,
like, you know, not to solve the greatest
problems of computer science. I wish I could
that. I'm really not that smart.
Like, you know, key versus NP and then
all that stuff. But,
I mean, I didn't think I was ever
gonna say I'm gonna build my own type
system, but, like, you know, I wind up
doing it.
But what we wanna do is, like, have
essentially a complete tool a complete tool chain,
a complete suite
that solves these problems that we're getting bogged
down, especially as humans
because
DevOps
and cloud infrastructure,
instead of, like, the left shift have worked
backwards from production. And I feel like now
we have sort of, like, this massive gap
in between. We have all this tooling
that, like, things like machines and treats things
like machines, and it works really well with
that. But once you hit the human, it's
kinda like, oh, you have to fill in
the gaps. Right? Like, here's the environments,
you know, the angles that you have to
fill out. Good luck. Find the values yourself.
Right? So
I'm not against, you know, the left shift,
and I'm not against developer tooling, but, like,
I think making it so that we can
connect the human better
to, you know, all the work that we've
done in the last ten or fifteen years,
I think it's sort of like we had
a developer gap actually is. Right? It's like,
how do we, you know, make no difference
between a human identity and a workload identity?
Right? And I think this amongst, you know,
all these other things is a way to
bridge that gap. Right? Is it perfect? Probably
not because it's very incomplete.
But I'm glad to hear that, like, I
just recruited David Flanagan as a as a
better user.
Hey. If I could give you a beer
or a high five right now, I totally
would like
I I could be happier to see this
feature in development. You and you mentioned something
earlier that but now it makes a whole
lot more sense. Was it you said you
were gonna support DuraEnf. Right? I'm assuming that's
part of this this work. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
So DuraEnf is is kinda, like, helpful in
two ways. Right? A, people already use it
in cat.
We'll be able to ditch a lot of,
like, extra code you put into your task
files
because, like, the way we share environments between
cells is not we don't we don't share
it the way a bash script would. We
actually snapshot the environment before and after and
then and then put it in this managed
environment store so we can also then port
it between modalities. Right? Modality, you're being a
notebook.
I mean, another thing that, like, you'll probably
see is we can also run blocks from
here.
And what we wanted to do is, like,
we didn't want people to fall into yet
another fault line between one modality into another.
So if you complete the environment over here,
it was really important to me and to
us that then when you run it on
another in another place that it has the
same values. Right? So this is why we
have this managed environment store.
So now the problem in the theory of
interest solving is, like, it's just a program
away of of, you know, I guess, specifying
a dot in file. Right? Because it allows
you to write shell.
The other thing that it allows you to
do is, like, there might be some prerequisite
steps, you know, whether it's, like, you wanna
run some stuff where,
you know, like, what's the command to get
the Google project. Right? It's like g cloud
config gets. Right?
You might just wanna run this and and
and and stash it into environment file. Sorry.
Into an environment variable to then use it
downstream in your documentation. You wanna run it
every time somebody starts a new session. Right?
So it kinda gives you the ability to
define
some prerequisite code that needs to run, in
this case, stash.
So it it it kinda checks a lot
of boxes, and then I also like the
way they authorize. Right? They they ask you,
like, are you okay with running this? Right?
It kinda fits into this runme philosophy where
we want things to be easy,
but we don't want them to be easy
at the expense of being secure.
Yeah. Cat was just saying that's one of
the things that blew our mind after already
adopting the tool. I mean, same for me.
I've been using runme for
weeks now, and I could not be more
excited for this end store. So that's amazing.
Right. And and, you know, that's something that
I wanna release, you know, ideally in the
next four weeks.
If you if you're really curious,
there is a little bit of documentation on
I mean, kinda like the principles of it
on the repository.
By the way, the managed environment, so I
call our store because, like, you know, when
you when you figure out the environment, that's
what you left with. Right? It's like,
I I blacked out the let's call it
freaking so we don't have to use exodus.
So it's called because also a much cooler
three letter acronym than inf. So internally, we
call it the.
But in in the UI, you will just
notice that there's another tab down here where
in the CLI, you can run snapshots.
But, you know, this is the idea is
very simple. Right? It's like it's a very
simple type system
that basically just describes how the environment needs
to look like, right, both from a security
standpoint so you don't leak secrets,
but then also has validation built in.
And then with this sort of, like, three
way relationship, you have a name, you have
a type,
and you have a value. You know, like,
when you have two, you can find the
third one. Right?
And the caveat here is, like, to find
the third one, you can take human identity
into account. You can take into account what
device you're running on. Right? Are you running
on a code spaces instance or on your
local laptop? Right? So there's a lot of,
like, security hygiene you can do out of
the box without burdening the user. Right? I
mean, whether it's, like, rotating certificates.
And I build it all on on GraphQL,
which I was, like, kinda, like, going back
and forth on until I thought I saw
the dagger was doing it too, I was
like, well, if they're doing it, then why
should I be doing it.
But what that helps me do is, like
and you don't have after I graph you
all. Right? This is really just to serialize
sort of what's going on inside of that
in store. This is all kind of inside
of a kernel.
The UI you interact with is this, right,
where,
you know, the specification file. But what it
allows us to do or, like, allows me
to do is, like, I can have a
simple dot end example file where I can
have a CRD or I can have the
the the sort of, like, on ramps into
how to specify
an environment that the front end for that
can be completely agnostic
to the environment store. Right? And and then,
you know, like, here,
you know, whether you use a shell command
to resolve the values, right, or you use
some custom webhook,
or you use the stateful products, or you
use a secret manager. Right? It's kinda programmable
in that way. So it kinda like yeah.
It really was to, like, leave the room
open for people to, like, be opinionated about
how they wanna resolve their configuration values and
their secrets. Right? If they wanna build their
own or if they wanna use what my
company builds or if they just wanna use
a vanilla, you know, secret manager inside of
AWS or or GCP.
Yeah. So, like, a lot of work has
gone into this,
and I feel like, you know, anytime I
wanna release it, I find something else. But
I think I just kinda have to jump
jump the shark
release it.
Awesome.
That is super cool.
Yeah. And, you know, if anybody is, like,
sort of computer science y and interested in,
like, how this stuff works,
it's all, like, a little go kernel.
And, you know, like, my plan would be
to continue to develop it inside of runme,
but, like, what I really wanna do is
spin it out into probably a tool called
OWL that
really only does this one thing, which is,
you know, specify,
validate, and resolve environment variables and and do
that in a way where you can use
human identity
and and workload identity. Right? And just kinda
do away with all these paper cuts. Right?
Yep.
Awesome. Yeah. So I took you on a
esoteric, you know, turn there, but I feel
like this is an unsolved problem of, you
know, software
and, you know, the the what is it?
The 12 factor movement has done a good
job separating configuration from the environment,
but sort of at the detriment of the
human. And I'm trying to close that gap
now. Right? And and I think it was,
you know, right to do that,
but it is annoying that we now, you
know, have nothing that makes this easy, and
I think this will resolve that problem.
No. I appreciate that segue down this path.
That is
you know, this is exactly the thing I
wanted. Well, not that I wanted to see
because I didn't know I was going to
see it, but the fact that now that
I know this exists
and that this problem is being solved makes
me a very happy man because
I have spent weeks in fact, probably months
going from secret manager tool to environment tool,
from dot env to dot env x to
in physical to Google secrets manager to one
password to Doppler.
I've been trying to just rack my brain
about how do I fix this because, you
know, we have config. We have secrets. They
have types. They have to be validated.
And it's Right. A solved problem. And now
I've just got the happiest smile on my
face ever because I know that you are
going down this path of fixing this thing.
And I I I will be your alpha
tester, your beta tester, and
Yeah.
I mean, I I wanna I wanna get
it to a point, honestly, and I think
this is totally possible doing a little bit
more of that work where going from one
secret manager to another is is changing one
line.
Mean, granted that you use the same conventions,
but, like, we could even have a transformation
step. Right? That uppercases it all remove, like,
make snake case out of it or makes
k pop case. Like, that sort of stuff
is also, like since it's so programmable,
it's it's you know, like, SOPs. Right? You,
like, even, like, delegate it to another tool.
But the idea is really to, like, do
all the front load, all the,
you know, the specification and the validation
that when you then, like, go reach into
it or, like, the other way around, when
you reach into it, then you can also
check, does it actually need the stack. Right?
Yeah. But But literally make that like a
no brainer. Right. And because you know how
to resolve all these values and you have
type information and you potentially know where these
values come from depending on how deep it
goes, you could do automatic secret rotation as
well. Oh, and it could run me and
all this other really cool. But, like, I
mean, you could be working on this for
the next six months, adding new features. I
don't think you run out of ideas.
I mean, I I built this thing because
I gotta talk into, you know, the the
rejects event at
at KubeCon in Europe. I had sort of,
like, a conceptual prototype, and then I got
to talk in. And then within four weeks,
I actually have to build it.
Was probably the most stressful part of my
life. Conference driven development at its best. Yeah.
That that my my wife was out of
town for, like, two or three weeks of
that.
And, you know, I guess it wasn't good
for my health, but but, you know, I
I really wanna get it out in front
of people. And I think there's a lot
of, like, sort of misconceptions around that that
problem is solved. Because people say, like, secret
management use vault, use you know, it's not
a it's not a it's an un it's
not an unsolved problem anymore,
and I I have to disagree. I think
it's solved in a way where we're giving
away all the bargaining chips to all these
big cloud providers. They lock us in, and
then we entirely remove it from the human.
Right? So, you know, like, I think this
is also why platform teams are so busy
because they have to bridge that gap using,
you know, like Jira tickets, right, or Zoom
calls. Right? And it's silly because it doesn't
have to be that way.
Wow. Alright. And that's just normally why I'd
say what's coming next, but you you've more
than covered that. So
Yeah. I mean, that's coming. The runme terminal
is probably gonna go out of better, like
the thing where, you know, it rolls up.
And, you know, the idea is really to
kinda connect the dots between
or, like, remove the the boundaries between the
modalities, right, so that, you know, people are
comfortable in the terminal. They can stay in
the terminal. We also wanna bring most of
that functionality
out of Versus codes. You know, there will
probably be terminal commands that, in other ways,
are gonna try to bring the same integrated
way together. It's a little bit more difficult
because,
you know, terminal is an island
and and really just kinda, like, continue to
do more of that.
And, yeah, like, I think for what it's
worth, like, know, just people kicking the tires,
telling us what resonates. Right? Like, I mean,
there's a lot of work we could be
doing. You know, like, I think we already
put a couple of things on that stack
of
what we could be doing on a road
map, but we really also wanna be user
user feedback driven. Right? So, you know, people
using it. I mean, you kick the tires.
I'm probably gonna go back to filtering and
searching the t y. Right?
I we really wanna unblock people. I usually
kinda, like, split my time between doing the
the things that come in and then the
larger development projects. Yep. And we're doing this
the same way with the team. Yeah. But
those are kinda, like, the more tangible, you
know, next couple of projects that are gonna
come.
Nice. Well, I would encourage anyone watching to
go check out the repository, get it installed,
start kicking the tires, open issues, and keep
you and the team busy because
this is a Discworks.
This is a product that just solves a
lot of paper cuts, right, frustrations from development,
especially for me. And I'm on a repository,
but or anyone doing cloud native microservices.
Right? We've got all this documentation and internal
knowledge that needs to become
shared and commoditized across your team and your
organization,
and runme is a fantastic tool to do
that. So thank you so much for building
it and for spending the last ninety minutes
of your life
dealing with my next source, but also showing
us some really cool stuff with what's coming
along. I love talking about this stuff. I
probably don't do it enough because I'm I'm,
you know, usually busy, like, trying to, like,
go down the the AST rabbit hole or,
like, the Alstor rabbit hole, but I appreciate,
you know, that you invited me to come
on the show. And, you know, maybe we
can do it again when the Alstor is
a little bit more developed and we can
kinda, like, really go a little bit deeper.
And, like, I think the resolution part of
it,
you know, is gonna be really important.
Tire kicking. Yes. Russell is kicking tires for
you now, so that is awesome.
Alright. Thank you again for joining.
And thank you for everyone that's watching. We're
gonna call it a a night. It's getting
late for me, but thank you so much.
And, we'll definitely check back in with you
and runme in
weeks and months time to see what's happening.
So thank you again. Have a great day,
and we'll see you all next time. Thank
you. Bye. Likewise. Bye.